to play this character who is heavily  improvised and then pair it with a  process that at once has to be filled  with life like you have to be completely  open and also detail-oriented down to  the tiniest minutia in order to make  marcel seem like his emotions aren't  just coming out of his mouth but that  they're in his body it's like a real  honor to have one of my performances  paired with that type of art because  there is so much dedication to that  intention that feels really good and  it's actually something we've tried for  marcel like in general you know with our  children's books all of the the images  in those books are oil paintings done by  an oil painter named amy lind i think  the thinking behind that has always been  that adults enjoy marcel and and  children do too one thing people don't  often give to children is like rich art  children deserve oil paintings they  should just have marcel in them you know  children deserve like  detailed detailed stop-motion